details tonight on the massive fire that
erupted yesterday at the silverstone
golf club the cause still unknown but
fire officials say this is the biggest
structural fire they have seen one of
the biggest within city limits in years
madison kimbrough joins us live near
what's left of that vacant golf club in
the northwest valley with the details
madison this isn't the first time that
golf club has caught fire right
it's not it's actually the third time
within this year that this building has
caught up in flames
when talking to firefighters many think
it may have been squatters who
previously started the flames but the
cause of the blaze that happened
yesterday is still unknown the fire
broke out around 12 30 friday afternoon
and continued to burn throughout the
night las vegas fire and rescue spent a
good seven hours before the flames were
primarily contained and due to previous
fires in this building firefighters had
to combat the flames from outside
usually in a smaller house we can get in
there we can get it under control pretty
quick get to the seat of the fire and
that's where we want to put the water
but in this particular case the building
is so big we couldn't find the seat of
the fire
and we weren't going to take a chance of
putting a firefighter in there where the
building looked like it might collapse
luckily no one was inside when the fire
started and no one was injured although
heavy smoke engulfed the neighborhood
near grand teton drive and buffalo drive
the golf club has been closed since
2015.
and there are still firefighters on
scene as you can see and zamanski said
the whole building is still a major hot
spot at this point so if you are headed
in this direction whether you live in
the neighborhood or you're on a bike
just be very very careful reporting live
in the northwest valley madison
kimbrough live local now